Tonight, a major loss for Trump.
A federal appeals
court ruling
unanimously that the former pres
is not immune
from prosecution
for alleged crimes he committed
to overturn the 2020 election.
Now, this is a crucial ruling.
It strikes down
the entire heart of Trump's defe
in the Department of Justice's
January six case.
Trump, for his part,
is slamming the,
quote, nation destroying ruling,
warning that it will cause
grave harm to America and the pr
It is a monumental decision
because it could have huge legal
and political implications.
So we're going to talk about
how this could affect the entire
now that this ruling has come do
whether he could be convicted be
Election Day. Crucial questions.
In a moment.
I want to bring in OUTFRONT now,
the former Trump White House att
Ty Cobb.
And Ty, of course, you signed
that amicus brief in the D.C.
Circuit
Court of Appeals arguing against
claims of immunity.
And obviously,
that is the way that this three
this three judge panel
ruled
unanimously saying
that Trump does not have immunit
I know you've had a chance
to read through it.
What stands out the most to you?
I think what stands out
the most to me is how
comprehensive and exhaustive
the opinion is with regard
to American history
and the evolution of constitutio
Back to Marbury versus Madison.
You know,
I think we discussed last week t
I didn't think people
should be overly concerned
about a three week delay.
But if we got into late this wee
you know, there might be cause
for concern.
With regard to delay, I think 28
to an opinion of this magnitude
and gravity,
you know,
I wish it had been sooner,
but at the same time,
I can see now why it was not
because this is this is an epic
This is an opinion.
If it's the last word on these i
as it may be, depending on what
the Supreme Court does.
I will be studying
law schools
for the next hundred
and 20 years,
along with other key
constitutional opinions
such as Marbury versus Madison.
I think the the unanimity
of this
of the three judges
and the per curiam
nature of the opinion
is a very, very important fact.
It will
well, I think it already has neg
the likelihood of
en banc review by the full court
of the D.C. Circuit.
And I think that
it will give the Supreme Court
some pause, both
because it gets these issues rig
and it doesn't,
you know, while it's compelling,
historic, monumental, it doesn't
too broadly.
They only decided
the few issues
that they needed to decide,
that they resolved
the jurisdictional issue wisely.
And in light of the constitution
posed by the double jeopardy
clause and impeachment,
which
while not explicit
constitutional grants of immunit
as suggested, are required
under middle and asphalt,
still clearly satisfy the import
nature of why they had to resolv
They also they also,
you know, limited it to this ind
this president, these circumstan
You know,
they didn't speak for future pre
They didn't speak for,
you know, future possible indict
They focused solely on this and
It's clear
that this judgment is limited to
So I know in that sense,
you're saying the Supreme Court
may not even take it up.
What about the argument
and I mentioned it
briefly introducing you,
but that Trump himself
made today
saying the decision would, quote
terribly injure the presidency
and in fact, the United States i
or all future
presidents would be targets
for political retribution.
American democracy would be at r
What's your response to such swe
terminology?
Well, I do believe that
if Trump is elected, that
President Biden
could be in danger of retributio
But I don't believe there's
a legal basis for it,
and I don't think it will go ver
The 44 presidents that preceded
President Trump did not waste a
I think,
debating whether they should com
an intentional criminal act.
So I don't really buy that argum
History doesn't suggest that it'
Trump also claimed
that the Supreme Court took away
his immunity.
That was immunity.
That is nowhere promised to anyb
And nobody since Nixon has belie
presidents are above criminal pr
So I think everything
he said
today is rhetoric designed for h
red meat,
and none of it's true.
All right.
Ty Cobb, thank you very much, as
We appreciate it.
My pleasure. Thank you, Aaron.
All right.
So Ryan Goodman is here with me,
in chief of Just Security
and on Cash could agree.
The former federal prosecutor
who wrote an article in New York
magazine titled
What Happens Exactly
If Trump is sentenced to Prison.
So, Ryan,
you know, listening to
Ty talking about the argument he
that was
that was given by the the
the judges today, the three judg
Your team
looked at the potential timeline
now that we have this ruling on
and here it came
right comes on this Tuesday in F
What does this mean
in terms of whether Trump's case
that this
this particular trial on January
six concludes before Election Da
So there's now a pretty good lik
it will conclude before election
We'll have a verdict.
And the court sets us up in moti
by saying that
by Monday, February
12th, Trump has to basically pet
the Supreme Court.
They force his hand,
and then the court gets to decid
whether or not
they want to take cert or hear t
And they'll probably make that d
around leap day, February 29th.
At that point,
you got two different tracks.
So track one is the court
decides not to take the case.
They just deny cert.
They say what?
Ty Cobb Just by saying it's not
Yeah, it's not worth it.
This is a solid decision.
It's a landmark decision.
It's narrow, it's confined,
and it is a unanimous decision.
So we just leave it be.
If that's the case,
then we're on a short track.
It goes right back to the trial
June 1st is a very good start da
to anticipate,
and then the trial
wraps up by September 1st.
That's the short time frame.
Then the longer time frame is
the court does hear the case,
but they will decide against Tru
in all likelihood.
He just doesn't really have a st
on that timeline.
Then we're looking at late
July, like July 30th start date,
October 30th verdict,
and that's conservative.
It could be like a week
before October 30,
but obviously bumping right up a
Right.
I mean, October 30th
is obviously the week
before the week before the elect
All right.
So because you've looked
at this closely as well,
if Trump is convicted. Right.
And as
as Ryan's laying out these scena
if that verdict is indeed
announced before
Election Day,
so you get a verdict,
then obviously there's
an appeals process.
What does the appeals process
look at that point?
And how long does that take?
Well,
so there would be a couple of mo
of a sentencing process
immediately following the convic
Then there would be an appeal.
And in the ordinary course,
an appeal from a proceeding like
after a verdict, you would
expect maybe 2 to 3 years.
In this particular case,
I would hope that if we get to t
that, you know, the appellate co
and the Supreme Court
would be expediting their review
because obviously there would be
an intense public interest
in having appellate courts
review that verdict
for any potential defects
or legal sufficiency.
So that's kind of the ordinary c
like two, three years
for the appellate chain to revie
But I would hope again,
if that's where this ends up,
that that would move more quickl
and move more quickly.
Interesting, though, rising on
because you said
you could get a verdict on the d
before Halloween,
theoretically or sooner. Right.
But you could get a verdict
as late as that.
But that would not mean you leav
Never mind the appeals process.
You might not get
you wouldn't get necessarily
a sentence, obviously. Right.
So that's a whole process, too.
You would simply get a guilty
or innocent initial verdict from
That's right.
So the American public will know
what a unanimous jury potentiall
and what they are finding him
guilty of if it's a guilty verdi
because then we can already begi
to calculate
what the likely conviction is
based on those particular crimes
the sentencing ranges, etc..
So, Ankush, in your magazine
article in New York magazine,
you identified a minimum
security prison in Florida.
That could likely be where Trump
If it goes, it would go
if he is convicted.
It's in Pensacola, about 8 hours
away from Mar a Lago.
And you spent some time looking
It's a it's a nice place for a p
tennis, volleyball or sunbathing
And you got to do a job
landscaping or working in the ki
No cell phone,
no Internet access are the limit
How did you land on this facilit
So it is the only federal prison
that is the closest
federal prison camp to Mar a Lag
Let me put it that way.
Federal prison camps
are the lowest level of security
in the federal penitentiary syst
and the Bureau of Prisons
has a preference for placing peo
if possible, or close to the res
where they will be released, to
which is Mar a Lago in this case
So Pensacola happens to be
the closest
federal prison camp to Mar a Lag
And so whether or not it's actua
you know,
if we end up there again,
that particular camp,
the general complexion
of sort of day to day
life in the facilities
is not that different
from place to place.
But that's how I identified it.
And Reno is fascinating, though.
And obviously,
you know,
we're we're a long way away from
But I think today
it comes real
certainly to the former presiden
in a way it may not have before,
that this is where this could go
Right, because it's going to go
There is going to be a trial fro
at least unless some shocking th
come from the Supreme Court.
Another option, though,
if this does happen,
is something like home confineme
That's right.
So home
confinement for a conviction on
charges would be unusual.
And generally the courts have sa
we're going to treat
Trump as any other citizen
like citizen Trump.
A former president
can't be above the law.
And even the conservative court
in the 11th Circuit,
all conservative judges
said the same thing
when it came to
the classified documents case.
So that's the question
that will be before the trial ju
Does he get treated like everybo
in which he does actually serve
in a minimum security prison
or maybe home confinement at Mar
a Lago with certain conditions?
And you could also say
he is somewhat different.
There's a greater security risk
He travels with the Secret Servi
Maybe home confinement
is a better situation.
All right.
Well, thank you both very much.
All of this real after all of th
and discussion
tonight in a way
that it has not yet been.